in this position and we have with us one
of the best players in the world he is
also a great friend to the club as he
does commentary in Russian and most
recently in English and there he is
freezing somewhere must be the high to
Siberia or is it just home Peters
fiddler with us welcome to the show
no I'm sporting the the copyrighted
Booker look obviously welcome to the
show it's so great to have you it's it's
stifling you fought inside this thing so
I'm gonna abandon the pretense that I'm
any kind of a poker player but now now
we'll be able to get tells on you Peter
I'm aware yeah this is the this is the
drawback well seriously appear I'm
talking a little bit about what's caught
your attention so far in the Sinquefield
Cup
well the the disparity between the the
sort of the character of the games and
the results of the games I think it has
to be I'm sure you're talking about this
every day because it's very hard to
avoid but like there there should not be
this few these few decisive games if you
look at what the games actually look
like and it's I don't have any I don't
have any explanation apart from you know
the usual platitudes that the field is
so strong and so even that you know
winning a game of chess is difficult
because everybody defends well nobody
will give you free points and so on but
yeah I mean obviously I'm sure there are
a lot of people on the internet saying
that this is yet again you know the the
decisive proof that classical chess is
in decline but if you look at how the
games are actually being played I don't
think that's true at all but the results
are somewhat weird now if you have to
say if you had to predict the winner of
the Sinquefield Cup yet Peter because we
didn't get you in our predictions base
based on those top three
is there anybody whose form you've been
particularly impressed by I think I
heard that you loved it England win yeah
I thought I thought the the Dingley ran
versus geary game was one of the bed
games of the year it's always very
difficult to rank these things because
it's sort of entirely subjective but it
stands out as a game you don't often see
between players of this strength because
I think Irish could be quite entitled to
think to himself I have not done much
wrong today
and yet I've been sort of completely
wiped off the board and that doesn't
happen very often in games between 27
you know 80 plus players and yeah I
thought that was that was excellent I'm
also enjoying a great deal the way sorry
the way wishes been playing let's do
something to the throat here yeah I I
really enjoyed the way vicious fish has
been playing this tournament and or with
was slightly better kind of run of the
run of the felt he could have been on
blast or even +3 arguably Peter by the
way we gotta get you a grand chest or
hoodie because they are fabulous why I
do that one I just didn't find it
scrambling to put something on and I but
I i raided the the shop the last time I
was there and I was completely shameless
wonderful rated rated yeah there it is a
is a beautiful hoodie but you can use it
for playing poker or chess but you talk
about Vichy and you know how many
opportunities he's had how do you read
his opportunities in this game against
one of the other I was the call started
Osterley enough for me to to to listen
to to Maurice explain that Bishop age
three appears to be a bit of a lemon and
I had a brief look and I think the point
is I mean Queen d3 does exist which kind
of stops g5 and and there are some
tactical opportunities there for black
as well but I suspect he did not really
miss 46 I don't think it's possible to
miss Roxy six it's the most obvious move
in the position
but something appears to have been
missed there and yeah I I think if
wishes ports all these tactics and sort
of upon the evidence of how he's been
playing this tournament I don't think
you can bet against him spotting the
proper follow-up and but once again if I
probably should start the feed because
without the field I'm not exactly sure
what you're showing on your screen right
now because we're looking at B six Peter
after Roxy six Queen b3 yeah but like do
we have the board because if I if I
start showing lines that might be tricky
just let us know what your take thinking
and yes yeah but NASA will try to keep
up
yeah the point I think is that after
Queen B 3 which hits the g5 pawn and
that's the important the important move
for white here to make because otherwise
g5 does appear to just capture the
knight on the 4 which is kind of
unfortunate to put it to put it mildly
after Queen B 3 and this is not this is
not me because I I tried to to get a
sense of what's going on and I did that
with the help of the Machine because I
didn't want to be completely full of it
it appears as if Knight b6 Bishop takes
c8 and 94 is very strong yes and that
would have to be there is a calculation
that has to be has to be first of all
you have to find that this idea exists
and then you have to calculate it
precisely because it's not immediately
obvious that this works out for black
all that well but I think the Machine
likes it and if the Machine likes it we
should probably also like it that's
that's the general general idea these
days so I have a feeling it's extremely
likely that ding was planning to play
Queen b3 and he wasn't very worried
about the knight on the for and the
precarious situation is finding itself
in because Queen b3 attacks the pollen
g5 laughter 96 Bishop takes e8 if black
does nothing spectacular the pollen i-5
is hanging for instance exactly so it
has to be this precise tactical tactical
short which
Misha will have to sport and evaluate
properly and go for but once again he's
been playing really well and there is no
reason for him not to not to do that but
Peter he's been missing those shots as
we see it looks as though Queen b3 has
been played from now that's really
there's really nothing else so it's
Peter you've been surprised to see this
she missed a couple of shots the the
Queen f1 was really complex in his game
against Wesley yeah we want to retreat
for sure but yesterday's game against on
each it felt like yeah yesterday was was
more disappointing to me to me as a
lifelong Vichy fan because it felt like
he had a position where I think in a
blitz game he would have just given mate
and he wouldn't have given a second
thought to this pawn on d5 because he
had such a beautiful attacking position
that his instincts would have been I
don't I don't need to win material here
it's a lot better it's a lot better and
a lot more efficient to just win win the
game by you know capturing the
opponent's king and instead he because
you know this not being a blitz game he
gave himself time to think and he
eventually went for something which was
more conservative it still gave him a
great position but it was a position
that was easier for foreigners to defend
he defended it really well and then I
think we'll smart a little bit for a for
Vichy because he will feel that he kind
of sold sold his advantage short there
and he will he will know that doesn't
that have a cumulative effect on you
missing one win he said he was he
couldn't sleep after missing the whole
queen of one idea as Knight b6 is on the
board we're gonna see whether or not he
finds his knight c4 move which will be
critical but that as a paternal player
when you look at Lou it's a couple of
games you said I should have had these
games how does it start to smart with
you as we saw nepo said the same thing
about himself he said he wasn't even
interested in the tournament after round
four because he wasn't applying while
and missing ideas and good positions
well neppo is obviously his slightly
overstating his disinterest I think but
if those
things do do pile up and and they do
start impacting your your further play I
know this would definitely be true about
myself and the hope has to be that this
she you know experienced warrior that he
is he hopefully handles it better than
than somebody like me because yeah he's
on +1 he is and the type of first it's a
it's a good situation to find himself in
but she should have been leading the
tournament after yesterday and but I
mean having a good position for the
second day in a row might be a very good
cure for whatever ill feelings he may he
may still have about yesterday
what about the grünfeld we know you're a
grin prospect yeah expecting yeah I'm
sort of smiling but it's curious
I actually went ahead and checked what I
was what I said in my series on the
green field about the Queen a4 check
line and Ruby Giovanna Paris appears to
be quite fresh because I'm actually
giving this entire line as my
recommendation in in the videos but
those were recorded I think three know
what three nominee at least five years
ago actually so sometime back and route
Yvonne was sort of non-existent in those
years and I did not feel like I need to
dedicate too much time to what that best
is a sideline and I gave sort of
official theory and the only move
instead of rogue Devon in those years
was Bishop g5 and there was quite a bit
of theory connected with the movie 55
here and that move I checked quite
carefully and I was quite convinced
black is folding but rogue Devon is new
and it's it's a bit curious because it
appears as if young equalised quite
comfortably by making some reasonably
natural moves and if you if you want to
you know if you're going for some kind
of a half idea in an opening like the
Greenfield you want to at least make
sure that your opponent cannot equalize
by playing what amounts to some version
of the most natural moves in the
position so I'm not entirely sure what
what Magnus is is is aiming for here and
when you say half idea you mean like an
opening where there you know there's a
road to equality but they might yeah we
use this term and it's kind of a
universally understood we serve within
the industry as something you play once
and you know you will not be able to
play it again because people will check
it with the Machine and the line will be
solved so so you do it once with the
expectation of maybe catching somebody
unawares and and winning that one game
that you played for the first time but I
don't think you know the position Magnus
has right now has much in a way of
actual winning chances so it's it's not
gonna bear too much too much fruit
seemingly so if you see the rooks can
hold against the Queen after it's seven
I think I think you have to go back to a
three because between take specifics
about Luke see one check would be a bit
of a mistake I think like if I just take
only three and play rook c5 and route 5
b6 I mean to my eyes the question is can
black play for a win the answer is
probably no but I mean how how are we
ever worse in this position exactly so
like I I think you can make half an
argument that black might not lose this
if you remove the b6 bone from the board
but that would be there would be
something muggles would be very
interested in but with the basic sport
still alive you just you just shuffle
enough for a draw and you you actually
hope that the rooks never get active
because if the roots somehow become
active here you might actually have to
work for it I remember Peter later
losing to democratic - exactly I mean
yeah just three
three up three on the Queen three three
and three yeah three and three is
supposed to be a draw but as that game
shows even at the extreme high level you
can still lose those if you are not
entirely careful so exactly yeah it's it
seems like a slightly slightly strange
choice to test best nepos been filled in
this particular way because I mean the
opening is healthy and and hail and all
that but there must be ways to just get
a playable position and play yeah you
know if I can take you away from the
sing field Cup 2019 for a moment and
bring up the chest 960 that you're gonna
be coming in town for and you know next
week talk to you about the challenges in
front of you and I'm not talking about
your airline travel it's it's I really
enjoyed the event last year last year I
thought it was it was very well
organized and also extremely interesting
I've always enjoyed the 960 as a variant
[Music]
yeah i've held the title for a foreign
beats a long time ago yeah more than 10
more than ten years ago but and I expect
it will be the same the same this year
I'm playing linear who I respect greatly
and I think it will be a very difficult
difficult much for me hopefully for him
as well but definitely and Garen yang
Gary's just and obviously yeah the big
news the big news and the main
attraction of course is the return the
return of Gary to-to-to over the board
chess and he does seem to take these
things reasonably seriously and this is
his serve one foray into competitive
chess per year like he's playing against
Bobby Otto and allenge himself at
fabiana's and number two rated player in
the
yeah Gary is not not sort of sharking
sharking the the firefights there
clearly and yeah will be very
interesting how to see how that goes
because are you intending to analyze the
wrong opening position again it's a fair
question
I'm really hoping I'm really hoping this
doesn't happen again
because that would be there would be a
bit of a disaster I barely lived it down
the first time and I don't think I will
actually survive the shame if it happens
again also do you guys is is shark just
no probably not
I understand we're talking about minus
60 but I'm for a second there I thought
Jeff was losing by force and I thought
it might be used maybe no I think I've
come probably overstating the problems
he's in I thought the HGH zero-g one for
step six and then I think rotation six
might actually win by force but I think
he's planning to play 95 and then f6 and
that's slightly more resilient 95 first
you know what if I first do to make sure
that the rope if okay six you can go
King g7 first now it's very important
King seven followed by B 56 and only
then we will play of seven f6 it still
looks very passive but if black actually
does establish this kind of a black sort
of dark square blockade it might not be
that horrible so just just a spasm that
might have been a forcing win good way
of getting away from that yes
they're speaking of chess let's just see
some position Peter if you if you may
inspect this one as well we've generated
a line that's showing some pretty brutal
tactics against ding Lorenz position and
it's right here after rook to c6 Knight
the knight Knight b6 on the board and
right here let's just take take a look
at a couple of lines guys rook takes c6
b takes c6 you know as an option as well
and after this move Bishop to ca there
are two really good ideas one is to
simply capture back another is still
this ninety-four idea coming into
position before taking as you're hitting
the bishop on D to the b-59 the c8
bishop but more directly instead of
fighting 94 queen takes on c8 and when
you save your knight to a3 actually i'll
make another move to show this point
clearer if you play Knight d6 trading
off it looks like Oh everything's good
no we're gonna do a simple trade and
queen h3 and the move Knight g4 is right
just unstoppable it's gonna be getting
crushing if after you're simply taking a
rook will show up there's no back back
mate oops
98 and you're getting mated here or
giving away your queen this yes it is
virtually winning for Anand and this is
what ding Lorraine is looking at yeah I
think doing is in in significant amount
of trouble here something has gone wrong
with in this transition from from the
opening into the middle game and he will
now have to find what's the best way of
defending this is he shouldn't resign
just yet the position is not sort of
completely beyond beyond salvation but
he isn't in quite some trouble obviously
and also just curiously I'm sure you've
remarked on this but Wesley is playing
with wide the line he played with black
against Rich Jerk in in the Moscow Grand
Prix right yeah and that's the game I
it's probably not not that funny of a
story but that's the game where famously
after g5 PG 5 Queen takes d5 Queen takes
d5 you have this position on the board
Sasha basically thoughtful like
from 15 to 20 minutes on the move Bishop
takes d5 which is strictly the only move
he can make in the position and he
wasn't even at the board because he in
this position in Moscow wide thought for
I think close to 20 minutes because
because basically in Moscow the Grand
Prix was held in the central chess club
and the central chess club and in
particular the hall where we played is
one of Sasha's most favorite places to
play chess and it has beautiful
full-length windows with you know
natural sunlight coming in and
everything and all of that was
completely draped in you know world
chess prefers this black and white
creepy atmosphere you you've seen this
before right they really like this this
very very stark creep like style and he
just didn't want to be there so he would
take every opportunity to think while
sitting on a sofa in the next room and
and but it's it was still quite quite
you know stunning too
I'm sure in particular for people
watching this online you know Quint XD
fibers on the board and it's not being
recaptured for a minute 2 5 10 15 and
you know you think what is going on
there but basically you take on d5 Blake
has only only repay c8 and reply and he
wanted to make two moves very quickly he
didn't want to think after Lucchesi
eight because then he would be forced to
spend time in that room right so he
thought so he thought before taking on
d5 and I just wanted to bring that up
for no reason whatsoever as you were
talking about him being away from the
board every way it was forcibly reminded
of a candidates match between Viktor
Korchnoi and Boris Spassky where Boris
Spassky stayed off stage he went
yeah his drawing was looking good
yeah that's very nice by the way guys we
have a jewel the first result of the
round as Yana Pagliacci and magnus
carlsen have drawn their game after a
perpetual of the Queen right and Peter
we're probably gonna get Magnus Carlsen
piped in for an interview but surely
comment on Magnus and how he might be
feeling after you know just failing to
draw blood here so far we will be
annoyed I think it's quite clear from
from his public utterances already that
in particular you know the 2019 he's had
prior to getting to st. Louis this will
this will annoy him a great deal lately
continued the continued non-winning of
chess games they're still after this
this is round seven yes so there's still
four to go there's still four to go and
nobody is really running away with it so
he's still very much in the running for
four top places in the eventual
standings but yeah he would clearly in
particular after the Rapidan blades he
would like to win one somewhere and
thank you so much to master a time
russian champion Peter Svidler
for joining us and sharing his insights
as we're getting max thanks for having
me
[Music]
you